letzte Woche haben wir über das schwarze
Loch aus interstellar gesprochen um
gaganthua kreist nämlich ein Planet auf
dem jede Stunde 7 Jahre vergehen und ich
wollte wissen ob es so einen Planeten
wirklich geben könnte doch danach
Achtung Spoiler fällt Cooper ins
Schwarze Loch hinein ab da nimmt der
Film eine sagen wir etwas künstlerische
Wendung und das ist total okay aber ich
wollte wissen was mit einem wirklich
passiert wenn man in ein Schwarzes Loch
hineinfällt denn schwarze Löcher sind
wie ich finde die faszinierendsten
Phänomene in unserem Universum also
fragen wir die Wissenschaft
[Musik]
ein schwarzes Loch ist eigentlich nur
eine sehr stark komprimierte Masse es
gibt nichts was die Masse aus der ein
schwarzes Loch besteht irgendwie
besonders macht ja sogar du könntest zu
einem schwarzen Loch werden wenn du dich
nur in einen sehr kleinen Raum zwingen
würdest wie klein nun die gesamte Erde
müsste zum Beispiel auf die Größe dieser
Kugel hier komprimiert werden um zu
einem schwarzen noch zu werden und alle
unsere Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem
würden zu einem schwarzen Loch werden
das gerade mal so groß ist in der
Realität sind es aber nicht Planeten die
zu schwarzen Löchern werden sondern
Sterne wenn sie Masse reich genug sind
implodieren sie am Ende ihres Lebens in
einer super Nova und dann werden sie zu
einem schwarzen Loch Planeten tun das
soweit wir wissen nicht und haben auch
eh nicht genug Masse dafür also was
definiert ein schwarzes Loch
vielleicht wisst ihr dass Masse die
Raumzeit krümmt das wird dann oft so
dargestellt das ist zwar nicht wirklich
akkurat weil die Darstellung zum
Beispiel nur zweidimensional ist aber
zum Verständnis finde ich das immer sehr
hilfreich sobald die Masse den Raum um
sie herum so stark krümmt dass nicht
einmal Licht entkommen kann in der
Sekunde ist es ein schwarzes Loch und
hier müssen wir direkt mal mit einem
großen Irrtum aufräumen denn ich glaube
dass viele denken dass das schwarze Loch
eine so starke Anziehungskraft hat dass
das Licht nicht wegfliegen kann und das
stimmt auch aber nicht weil das schwarze
Loch an den Photonen direkt sieht
sondern weil das schwarze Loch die
Raumzeit so stark krümmt dass alle
Orbits wieder zurück zum Schwarzen Loch
führen quasi alle Wege führen nach oben
nur das rum das schwarze Loch ist egal
in welche Richtung du gehst du kommst am
Ende immer wieder im Schwarzen Loch an
übrigens ich spricht die ganze Zeit von
dem Schwarzen Loch dabei gibt es nicht
das eine schwarze Loch sondern mehrere
verschiedene nach ihrer Masse sortiert
sind das Prim ideale schwarze Löcher
stellare schwarze Löcher mittelschwere
und super massereiche schwarze Löcher
letztere befinden sich übrigens meistens
in den Zentren von großen Galaxien dazu
muss man aber sagen dass man bisher nur
stellare und super massereiche schwarze
Löcher beobachten konnte
mittelschwere schwarze Löcher müsste es
theoretisch geben da ist stellare zu
supermass erreichen Schwarzen Löchern
verschmelzen und die mittelschweren
quasi der Zwischenschritt sind das
mittlere Pokémon in der Evolution wenn
man so will
primordiale schwarze Löcher existieren
erstmal nur in der Theorie und dann gibt
es da noch akustische schwarze Löcher
die wir hier auf der Erde erzeugen
können aber das verdient glaube ich ein
eigenes Video von außen betrachtet
reichen übrigens alleine die Masse der
Dreh Impuls und die elektrische Ladung
aus um alles zu beschreiben was es über
Schwarze Löcher zu beobachten gibt und
das ist ja irgendwie mega faszinierend
oder überlegt mal wie viele Attribute
man bräuchte um die Erde komplett zu
beschreiben alle Berge alle Meere
Vulkane Wolken Tiere alle Menschen und
alles was es sonst noch so auf der Erde
gibt schwarz Löcher brauchen nur diese
drei Werte um sie von außen in ihrer
Gänze zu beschreiben sie sind nämlich
glatte Kugeln und haben keine Haare wie
ist John Mila gesagt hat sie haben keine
Frisuren die sie abgesehen von diesen
drei Parametern individuell kennzeichnen
was uns zu einem weiteren Mythos bringt
der klassische Kindheit Albtraum von
einem Schwarzen Loch eingesaugt zu haben
vielleicht weil immer gesagt wird dass
nicht einmal Licht ihnen entkommen kann
oder weil schwarze Löcher tatsächlich
sehr hohe Anziehungskräfte haben aber
irgendwie denken viele das schwarze
Löcher wie Staubsauger sind die alles im
Universum einsaugen und für immer
verschlucken und nun ja selbst das
stimmt irgendwie aber sie saugen eben
nicht anders als die Erde oder die Sonne
Sachen ansaugen oder besser anziehen
nämlich mit ihrer Gravitation ein
schwarzes Loch mit der Masse unserer
Sonne würde ohne Probleme unsere Sonne
ersetzen können wenn das von jetzt auf
gleich der Fall wäre würden wir
weiterhin auf unserer Bahn um das
Zentrum herum kreisen nur dass wir
natürlich nach 8 Minuten kein Licht mehr
abbekommen würden und wahrscheinlich
alle erfrieren würden aber die Erde
würde weiterhin einmal im Jahr einen
Orbit vollführen und wir würden vom
Schwarzen Loch nicht eingesaugt werden
genauso wenig wie millas Planet in
Interlaken von Schwarzen Loch eingesaugt
wurde okay aber was wäre wenn du jetzt
doch aus Versehen in ein Schwarzes Loch
fallen würdest nun
zum einen wäre das tatsächlich sehr
schwierig selbst die Raumsonde Solar
Orbiter muss extrem komplizierte
Flugbahnen vollführen um zur Sonne zu
gelangen obwohl sie ja eigentlich alles
in unserem Sonnensystem anzieht
orbitalmechanik ist weird aber gut sagen
wir du schaffst es trotzdem irgendwie
dann solltest Du gut versichert sein nur
welche Versicherung greift da jetzt auch
im Alltag wirkt das Thema für viele
ähnlich kompliziert wie orbitan-mechanik
aber vielleicht ist es ja eine eurer
guten Vorsätze fürs neue Jahr euch mal
intensiver mit euren Versicherungen
auseinanderzusetzen und genau dabei kann
euch Clark unterstützen über die Clark
App habt ihr alle eure Versicherungen im
Überblick und könnt euch kostenlos dazu
beraten lassen das kann helfen relevante
Dinge abzusichern oder Geld für unnötige
Versicherungen zu sparen was natürlich
gerade im Moment mega praktisch ist
wichtig zu wissen klagt tritt als Makler
für euch auf das ist hilfreich wenn ihr
alte Versicherungen einfach kündigen
oder neue abschließen wollt es wird aber
auch relevant wenn ihr schon einen
Makler habt der verliert dadurch nämlich
sein mand an Clark das solltet ihr also
unbedingt beachten wenn ihr jetzt eure
Versicherungen mit Clark optimieren
wollt dann geht einfach auf den ersten
Link unten in der Videobeschreibung oder
scannt den QR-Code hier und geht bei der
Registrierung den Code Watson ein damit
bekommt ihr für bis zu drei bestehende
Versicherungen je einen 15 Euro
Gutschein zum Beispiel für Cyberport
Amazon oder den App Store und natürlich
unterstützt ihr damit auch noch uns und
unsere Videos vielen Dank okay wo waren
wir ach ja du fällst gerade in ein
Schwarzes Loch wie sieht das aus
nun die Antworten unterscheiden sich für
dich der in ein Schwarzes Loch fällt und
mich der das ganze von außen beobachtet
sorry für mich wird das Licht rot
verschoben das heißt die Wellen werden
in die Länge gezogen sodass sie immer
rötlicher und immer schwächer werden ich
würde also sehen wie du immer rötlicher
und immer dunkler wirst bist du
irgendwann ganz verschwindest und nie
wiederkehrst aber für dich sieht die
Sache ganz anders aus wenn du in ein
Schwarzes Loch hineinfällst dann fühlt
es sich nicht an als würdest du
eingesorgt werden sondern du schwebst
einfach nur natürlich fällst du in
Wahrheit aber ein freier Fall fühlt sich
schwerelos an du solltest diesen Moment
unbedingt genießen denn viel Zeit bleibt
dir in diesem Universum nicht mehr du
warst gerade auf deinen Tod zu
zuerst kommst du an der photonensphäre
vorbei das ist eine Fläche auf der
Photonen in einem instabilen Orbit um
ein schwarzes Loch herum kreisen können
sowie Planeten um die Sonne kreisen
können auch Photonen dank der
unglaublich stark gekrümmten Raumzeit
hier um ein schwarzes Loch Kreisen wenn
du dich in der photonensphäre zur Seite
drehst dann kannst du theoretisch deinen
eigenen Hinterkopf sehen das
reflektierte Licht von dem Hinterkopf
fliegt einmal komplett um das schwarze
Loch herum und fällt dann von vorne in
deine Augen etwas weiter in Richtung
schwarzes Loch kommt der Ereignis
Horizont die Grenze ab der nichts mehr
aus einem schwarzen Loch herauskommt
nicht einmal Licht manche Theorien
besagen dass man spätestens hier sterben
würde andere gehen davon aus dass nichts
Besonderes passieren würde und man gar
nicht merken würde wann man genau den
Ereignis Horizont überschreitet so oder
so mitteilen könntest du es dem Rest des
Universums nicht mehr jede Art der
Kommunikation ob per Radio oder Licht
wählen selbst über qu verschränkte
Teilchen bleibt im Schwarzen Loch und
nein man kann sich auch nicht an einem
Seil oder Kabel festhalten und nur mal
kurz reinschauen sobald man einmal
hinter dem Ereignishorizont ist gibt es
keinen Weg mehr zurück du wirst bald auf
jeden Fall sterben je nach Größe des
Schwarzen Lochs passiert das übrigens
sogar schon vor dem Ereignishorizont und
spannender Weise sind kleinere schwarze
Löcher hier bei gefährlicher als großer
wenn du mit den Füßen voran auf das
schwarze Loch hin schwebst dann erfahren
deine Füße eine höhere Gravitation als
dein Kopf sie werden stärker angezogen
und damit wird ein ganzer Körper
auseinandergezogen die Kräfte werden
immer stärker bist du irgendwann
auseinandergerissen wirst am Ende bist
du nur noch ein langer Strahl aus heißem
Plasma der zum Mittelpunkt des Schwarzen
Lochs gezogen wird du siehst dann aus
wie eine Spaghetti was ist Stephen
Hawking zum ersten Mal so genannt hat
und deswegen heißt dieses von denen nun
offiziell in wissenschaftlichen Papern
kein Scherz spaghettisierung soll einer
sagen Wissenschaftler hätten keinen
Humor
nun bist du also tot aber deine Masse
wird weiterhin mit einer unglaublichen
Geschwindigkeit zum Mittelpunkt des
Schwarzen Lochs gezogen zur Singularität
und was da passiert nun das ist
unmöglich zu sagen die Gesetze der
Physik brechen hier zusammen denn die
Raumzeit selbst kollabiert in der
Singularität treten immer mehr
Quanteneffekte aufgrund der
mikroskopischen Größenordnung auf welche
in der Relativitätstheorie einfach nicht
berücksichtigt werden es braucht also
eine neue Theorie die vorher sagt was
auf sehr kleinen Längen Skalen unter
großer Gravitation passiert ohne diese
Theorie kann man nicht sagen was an oder
in der Singularität passieren wird es
ist physikalisch einfach noch nicht
verstanden doch nicht einmal definiert
aktuell ist man sich nicht mal sicher ob
es überhaupt eine Singularität gibt das
heißt alles was man bisher darüber
gehört hat was hinter dem
Ereignishorizont passiert sind erstmal
nur Theorien und nichts davon ist bisher
belegt
zum Beispiel dass man den gesamten
zeitlichen Verlauf des Universums sehen
würde hier vergisst man den
Dopplereffekt und die Aberration des
Lichts andere Theorien besagen dass man
hier Wurmlöcher zu anderen Orten im
Universum oder gar zu Paralleluniversen
findet oder das ist hier 10.000
Bücherregale gibt
nun das alles ist nicht falsch solange
wir es nicht widerlegen können und wir
werden es vermutlich nie so richtig
widerlegen können weil es nach unserem
aktuellen Verständnis unmöglich ist ein
schwarzes Loch von innen zu untersuchen
ach ja und wenn das alles noch nicht
kompliziert genug war alles was ich in
diesem Video bisher gesagt habe bezog
sich auf nicht rotierende schwarze
Löcher nach unserem aktuellen
Verständnis rotieren aber alle schwarze
Löcher in unserem Universum und das
sorgt noch mal für viel mehr komplexe
Physik und Mathematik z.B kann es hier
mehrere ereignishorizonte und
mathematische Instabilitäten geben und
auch die ergosphäre das ist ein Bereich
außerhalb des ereignishorizonts in dem
es unmöglich ist still zu stehen
zumindest von außen betrachtet müsste
man sich mit über Lichtgeschwindigkeit
bewegen weil die Raumzeit von sich
drehenden schwarzen Loch mitgerissen
wird aber woher wissen wir dass es
schwarze Löcher überhaupt gibt sie sind
doch sehr Definition unsichtbar weil
kein Licht mehr herauskommen kann
nun schwarze Löcher selber ja aber die
Masse die in sie hineinfällt ist
ironischerweise super hell weil sie
teilweise super heiß wird und genau die
kann man fotografieren und wie das
geschafft wurde das könnt ihr euch hier
anschauen wie immer vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric